nous avons un dicton sur asgard d' quand
on voit les oreilles du loup cédant ne
sont pas loin
c'est un piège
il ment il nous manipulent j'ai failli
me faire avoir loki moi aussi je les
aurais pas dû
voilà le topo
invariants fuite tuno minuteur depuis un
moment
n'avons pas trouvé par nous mêmes
alors on a besoin d'un expert c'est moi
ce criminel peut être n'importe où
n'importe quoi
la prudence s'impose tout ce que nous
ferons peut impacter le cours de
l'histoire vous comprenez ok ok
[Musique]
les gardiens du temps supervise le
moindre aspect de cette affaire
deux fier à lui n'est pas une excellente
idée
aucun homme mauvais n'est totalement
mauvais
[Musique]
et qu'aucun homme bon n'est totalement
pont
ça n'a rien à voir avec tour à d'accord
[Musique]
wendel
dire que je croyais bêtement
que vous pouvez être n'importe qui
puisqu'un bien
je devrais être protégé pas me sentir en
danger c'est presque insultant ou une
sonde raid on jamais
[Musique]